hey guys how's it going so I'm gonna be
doing a full unboxing of all the Apple
watches for my tech Tuesday so that
video be out this Tuesday so I'm excited
to show you all of the new ones almost
all of the new ones which I'm actually
glad that I didn't get all of the new
bands because I noticed a little
something here while doing the unboxing
the nylon band bold royal blue and the
nylon band Gold red are the same exact
watch band now I'm gonna stay completely
neutral I'm not going to say if I'm
upset about this or if I'm excited about
this I'm just going to stay completely
neutral and I would like to know what
you guys think in the comments below so
as I was looking at these I was like wow
that's really strange when I flip over
the gold royal blue it is the exact same
color on the opposite side it's the gold
red gold blue the only way that you're
actually able to tell the difference is
the 42 millimeter and the woven nylon
logos are her supposed to be on the
inside of your wrist so you're
essentially buying two separate bands
but in the same exact band but they went
and put the logo on the inside I feel
like these could have been reversible so
that was just my little thing that I
noticed during the unboxing
I am definitely always into having some
new Apple watch bands because I know a
lot of people might criticize the Apple
watch but I use it on a daily basis I
always used to wear watches as an
accessory not necessarily as a
functional item so now I actually do
wear my Apple watch for messages to
actually tell the time and to have a
full calendar to be able to see what
events I have coming up or anything like
that and I do sometimes use the hey Siri
today but okay Shh no not you sometimes
I use the hey Siri function to be able
to send text messages or leave myself
notes but all at all I'm really into the
Apple watch I like it the one that I'm
currently wearing right now is the rose
gold aluminum with the new pink band I
was too excited to do an unboxing of the
pink band so since I came in I was like
open it immediately and put it on my
wrist some things that I am looking
forward to that are coming out for the
Apple watch is the new Apple watch OS so
with that new operating system you'll be
able to pair multiple watch faces with
your phone I believe I might have
discussed this in some previous Apple
videos but for people who might own more
than one Apple watch face you'll be able
to easily switch between the two instead
of unparalleled lianas with you I would
be perfectly fine just having this steel
one it matches pretty much everything
but I wear a lot of rose gold so being
able to have this rose gold watch face
I'm able to switch it up and wear for
different events and different occasions
if you're a girl or if you're a guy that
really cares about that sort of thing it
is nice to be able to have different
options and sort of style your Apple
watch I wear my Apple watch on red
carpets and I don't care I will wear it
everywhere I have obsessed with it and I
love it and I look forward to posting my
Apple watch band review that'll be out
on Tuesday so I'll see you guys then
happy MIDI tech Tuesday on a Saturday
I've got a really fun Easter video for
you guys tomorrow
have a great weekend I'll see you soon
the holes ain't out